Hi Michael, so that covers Decision Trees
>> Excellent.
>> So, since you are the one who is listening,
you get to tell me what we have learned today?
>> Well, we learned about the Decision Tree representation,
we learned the top down algorithm for inducing
a Decision Tree. And we call that ID3
>> All right. So we got a representation,
we got a top down learning algorithm ID3.
>> We learned about the, the expressiveness and the bias.
>> Right. So those are 2 separate things, we learned about
the sort of expressiveness. And we learned about the bias of ID3.
>> And we gave one, so is this specific to ID3? We, we looked at one specific
way of deciding on splits, which was to do this maximum information game.
>> Right. So we talked about in general,um, what are good attributes or what
are best attributes. So, information gain is
one way of doing it. As one example.
And, by the way, this notion of best attribute is something we'll end
up returning to sometimes explicitly, and
sometimes implicitly, throughout the entire course. And
lastly, I feel like we talked about the problems with over-fitting and how
in the Decision Tree context, you can prune back the tree to avoid over-fitting.
>> Over-fitting is an issue. Over-fitting is always an issue and
we came up with a couple of strategies for dealing with over-fitting
in the context of Decision Trees. Okay! So we've learned everything
there is to know about Decision Trees, there's nothing else to know.
>> [LAUGH] Somehow I find that hard to believe.
>> Yeah, there's a lot there and the students will get
a chance to learn even more as they do the assignments.
>> Cool.
>> Excellent. All right Michael, thank you.
>> Sure, look forward to the next chat.